nous contre l'amour est dans le pré ceux
qui sont pour sur la soupe qui sont
contre et sont là on a et on a alors
tiré aux livres qui tuent avec nos amis
les uns comme à la voix de crooner ça va
voter on va revoir des images qui te
fait la boulette des au départ des
séries tout à l'heure tu as dit que
c'était moi qui avais mais j'étais pas
bien c'est aussi ça sert de faire un
coup d'état
c'est aussi le thierry labelle la
dernière fois j'étais jaloux 20 et elle
a accueilli avait dansé avec enora bois
alors monsieur on va parler de l'amour
est dans le pré parce que voilà il y en
a qui ça a brisé des vies dany est avec
nous il est contre l'amour est dans le
pré dany vous étiez dans la même saison
saison 7 d'ailleurs tous les deux vous
avez des visions bien différentes de
l'amour est dans le pré puisque vous
thierry ça a changé votre vie dans le
bon sens et vous dans le mauvais sens
alors à propos de l'amour est dans le
pré est déjà un ancien candidat
aymeric a dénoncé les effets secondaires
de sa célébrité ainsi que comportement
de certaines prétendantes il est harcelé
et oui les arts se dit peu comme vous ah
non pas du tout pour ce débat il a dans
l'émission oui oui mais regardez les le
quart d'heure où il ya mon portrait et
j'avais reçu 139 nouvelles demandes
d'amis ouais il même qui m'a alors qu'il
avait déjà écrit un mail à la production
qui avaient été contactés et elle
voulait vraiment sortir du lot dans cas
du coma verrons bien à la lettre aux
histoires si mon adresse m de
l'exploitation et l envoyer un colis
avec plein de cadeaux d' assez sympa
quoi mais elle aurait dû s'arrêter là et
on a un coût dont du coup je sors de mon
champ puis bajawa qui sort qui débarque
donc avec soin de venir en vacances ici
pour pouvoir ou s'il sait que j'habitais
dans la conversation je me rappelle
qu'elle a une petite fille dont je m'en
mets avaient été mis tout seul ou qui
ploie annonce une aide à des normales à
dans ma voiture ma fille avec ma mère et
ma grand mère
là pas de bon sens je leur ai demandé de
se décaler n'a pas de bon sens alors
donc lui voilà vous avez vu il est il
est harcelé aymeric n'est pas le seul
candidat qui garde un mauvais souvenir
de l'émission peut citer patricia elle
regrette d'avoir participé à l'amour et
dans lequel elle remet notamment en
cause le montage on a une vidéo d'elle
où elle galère dans un escalator
regarder oui c'est vrai que l'image
n'est pas très flatteuse et ça l'a
embêté convoi scindé rémy est tellement
forte pour patricia qu'elle tente en
vain forcément de prendre les squatteurs
à contresens
et ce n'est pas tout elle tire sa valise
à l'envers les roulettes dans le mauvais
sens
et cette jeune fille eh bien elle
explique qu'elle a très mal vécu cette
vidéo puisque à cause de ça sa vie est
devenue à calvert la peau cet épisode
m'a fallu énormément de moqueries sur
internet et souvent ce sont des
critiques si hop est très belle et très
déplacé
j'étais très énervé et fatigué parce
qu'on avait fait faire un trajet de huit
heures en train ça arrive à tout le
monde mais je m'en veux parce qu'au
final tout est tourné à notre
désavantage les montages nous salissent
tous allant de dany pourquoi vous avez
regretté d'avoir fait l'amour est dans
le pré déjà inscrit
à commencer par le début je tape un
petit morceau de compte est celle où
j'adore vais pas de département ouais
c'est vrai que du côté de chez vous
voilà en guise les bienvenus ensuite il
faut partager le curé d'un défaut
partagé que saurions je prends pour moi
et a dit je vais partager avec des amis
je ne crois pas ensuite je vais répondre
à ta question
oui première chose que je tiens à dire
publiquement c'est que tu vois quoi je
vais je joue de l'accordéon donc géré et
offert au public
ouais première chose on n'est pas payé
pour passer à l'amour dans le prix il
faut bien des prix à payer
non on n'est pas payé dans les veillées
vous êtes c'est tout jacques là pour
trouver l'amour ou alors effrayée
c'est le verre défrayer donc défrayer
bain par exemple si on vient à paris
nous payer ça fait rêver tout ça ce qui
est logique et je crée je critique pas
ça mais il ya plein de gens qui donnent
qui pensent que parce que je suis
passera télévision je suis devenu riche
non alors attention oui on n'est pas sa
télé on a comment notre petit comment
l'autorité mais c'est pas pour autant
après on est agriculteur comme la fille
qu'on vienne devant sa race et on
reprend le travail derrière
voilà on n'est pas acteur de cinéma nous
donc
alors pourquoi vous avez regretté
d'année alors pourquoi j'arrive il était
tout simplement j'ai été le seul arrêté
l'émission avant la fin parce que je
suis franc comtois et jeckel quand j'ai
quelque chose à dire je le dis ouais et
donc simplement j'ai une fille qu'à 12
ans chaque fois que je passe à la cool
ma fille ce fait à chaque fois que ma
fille que je passe à la télévision
pardon ma fille se faisant un bta
l'école est aujourd'hui ma fille à
l'école en suisse elles portent pas mon
nom je ne vais plus à chercher à sortie
de l'école
non oui oui cyril parce que en fonction
de compte il passe à la télévision
thierry est passé pour un bon tant mieux
pour lui moi je suis passer pour un con
alors alors on va voir l'annexé on va
voir vraiment on a fait une compile de
dany parce que là ce qui nous dit opposé
à droite
rendez compte sa fille d'à p y'a plus
qu'à finir le travail
dans un instant on regarde plus pas fini
on m'y attendais vraiment des coups de
coeur et moins coûteux pour elle
s'appelle lna elle assume touché rapport
à la vie qu'elle mois pour trouver le
réconfort d'apaisement l'apaisement
et aussi elle est allée joly ah oui
j'aurais lennon donc tu as de la hausse
en fait tant que ça peut
c'est pas tellement loin de chez moi là
non oui même si c'est pas tellement loin
est ce que oui je serai peut-être à te
quitter si c'est ce que steve et ça va
[Applaudissements]
donc danny way vraiment alors tu as dis
je c'est fou ce qui t'arrive insiste
louis congé arrêter l'émission série
j'ai aidé un jour il y en a un qui va
succéder
et ce coup là ça fait 2 de l'amour est
d'impliquer suicide et bien sûr c'est
pas de la faute de la télévision c'est
pas de la faute de leurs mauvais nancy
je pense que c'est la règle quand même
parce que c'est propre à toutes les
émissions
corinne atlas et quand on est célèbre on
attend à ce que je veux dire c'est que
excuse moi de ce que je veux dire c'est
madame le marchand dit que son émission
c'est pas une émission de télé réalité
eh bien c'est exactement ça fait bien
sûr alors j'arrête quelqu'un défendre
s'il vous plaît j'ai vu toutes les
saisons et que j'ai bien venue d'annie
alors les maires plus beaucoup qui était
l'un de mes préférés quel d'ailleurs
fait un hymne aux agriculteurs sur
l'accord de lolita pas vous mais moi je
suis de passer pendant six semaines
ouais en revanche dany manifestement
vous demandiez à l'émission ce qu'elle
ne pouvait pas vous donner vous aviez
des idées préconçues
dans l'émission pas de souci non en fait
je dis que les défis
enfin ils peuvent pas tous passer alors
bien sûr et peuvent pas tous passer mais
pourquoi il passe le pire
par exemple il y avait notre anr nous
michel edouard un gars hyper timide et
le montre en slip au milieu de la salle
de bain ça c'est respecter la partie des
lilas et t il à il a été vraiment tout à
yomou tranche tepa
ils étaient ils étaient hyper timide et
nous montrions ce type à la télévision
je veux quelqu'un qui a des séquences
qui pourrait nous épargner vous êtes en
cause que défend sa tête quelqu'un qui
veut défendre moi pardonnez moi mais je
alors je peux comprendre qu'il y ait des
soucis pour votre fille et c'est le
formation c'est un petit peu le jeu
aussi à quoi comme moi il y en a eu des
hauts mais quand on passe à la
télévision évidemment je pense que vous
que je ne peux pas imaginer un instant
que vous n'ayez pas soupçonner à quel
public non mais non abonnés
après est par ailleurs vous avez vous
êtes apparu extrêmement sympathique mais
oui non les gens mais si je pense qu'il
ya ait évidemment vous aurez toujours
même s'ils ont fait de vrais le plus
élogieux du monde des gens qui ne vous
avons pas parce que c'est la règle du
jeu malheureusement mes questions les
réseaux sociaux leurs autres on viendra
vous déjà alors il y en a qui est pas du
tout d'accord c'est une élection c'est à
dire que ben voilà comment poste l'amour
dans le pré dans l'émission alors on
nous fait passer à une femme depuis
cologne lors elles soient d en bas j'ai
pensé d'une scie colloque paula vu que
j'étais à peu près normale s'est fait
passer parce que toi chérie tu es très
content de ton aventure dans l'amour est
dans le pré bah oui mais moi j'ai
toujours tapé sur des casseroles de
façon on va regarder rives du bonheur
bon bah on va nous dire pourquoi toi tu
es heureux d'avoir participé à l'amour
est dans le pré
contrairement à danny way je suis quand
même un agriculteur qu'il faut pas dire
parce que les gens c'est vrai ils le
disent on passe à la télé on est riche
mais non on n'est pas riche à passer aux
joueurs de l'est chez nous si nous la
normandie je tiens à souligner à nos
deux laiteries ne payent les 325 euros
la tonne elle nous a dit il ya quinze
jours ils vont baisser 15 centimes
lorsque la tonne de beurre fait que de
monter ans à tous les âges et surtout
s'était jointe aux élections je vois
quelque chose c'était la manche
d'habitude la normandie au moins 5
michel
on n'a jamais de sécheresse et bien
croyez moi si vous voulez vous regardez
c'est internet
j'ai fait du x l'ascension au mois de
mai et je tenais au mois de juillet
gerber c'est vrai je projette du foin on
pense à tous ces 160 mille litres de
lait j'ai même pas 200 mille litres de
lait lorsque aujourd'hui vous avez des
fermes à des millions de litres d'eau
les messages sur petites fermes et durs
on va regarder tout à fait dans la
saison c'est la même saison les séries
de belleville huit séries il regrette
pas d'avoir fait l'amour est dans le pré
regarde un an à peu près construit et
met en scène deux corps encore plus fort
corps qui avant
il m'a chopé maintenant de mon lit je
t'emmène dans mon lit non c'est pas tout
à fait ça n'a pas bien compris
[Musique]
maki jour mon oreiller
et si vous
alors si vous nous rejoignez on est en
direct sur ces mutations s'est tous pas
mon poste et on a chip du temple à
thierry thierry draguera isabelle tout à
l'heure il est avec nous et d'animaux
rhodanie il regarde un souvenir
excécrable de l'amour est dans le pré
mine de rien tu regarde vraiment de
l'avoir fait dany toi vraiment ça
changer ta vie dans le mauvais sens il
doit thierry va décrire ça pourrait être
une bonne émission je critique pas
l'émission c'est très belle émission jeu
crytek la façon dont tu es folle
émissions alors tu sais que c'est de la
télé aussi celles des films et séries
respectives de dire un mot faudra partir
vite pourquoi toi tu es pourquoi ça a
changé d'avis dans le bon sens soit
écouté heureux eh ben j'ai jamais été au
collège et je le connaissais même pas
même ma géographie je pensais même pas
paris non et de belles aujourd'hui tous
les départements ma vie ouais j'ai tombé
en coeur des gens il ya des familles
pleurent de deux heures de suite des
fois heureusement qu'on a des gens qui
me tient parce que je déshabiller je
vais regarder le mariage
les vigiles m6 annie elle avait peu de
fleurs c'est sa robe way home ou de
tirer de partout et pas qu'avec à un
mètre tapas et on va regarder les vidéos
tube alors détecté que tu en es boutoir
au niveau du mariage d'intérêt
savoir-faire six ans dans le cadre joue
[Applaudissements]
les regarder aujourd'hui je me suis
juste la bio costumes pour me marier
dans quelques heures quoi thierry philip
rendre eolys
on sent chez vous à prendre pour épouse
madame annie emeline verront ici 4,8 au
nom de la loi
nous récupérons puni de marjah
[Musique]
demain
et oui donc chérie ça fait six ans qu'il
est marié thierry jeux amoureux et ma
femme a travaillé à la du travail bon
bah je suis très jeune doit pas dire à
bagnolet on vient corps à sarcelles voit
le papy c'est un oeil le marché de
sarcelles les jaunes se fait sur mon nom
mais on comprend alors vous vous êtes
contre d'amour entre mathieu de louis ce
sont des gens qui ont des codes la
production qui ont des codes de la télé
qui travaille avec déjà et qui vont
filmer des gens qui n'ont pas les codes
de la télévision il rit pas avec eric
deux noms pour le coup on part donc je
sais de quoi je parle parce que tu
konaté gestion chez b les miennes on a
fait une émission ensemble c'est vrai ou
pas à l'époque pouf
non sans rire il était très malheureux
était vraiment très très malheureuse qui
était diffusé il nous disait à l'époque
c'est effectivement que pour se [ __ ]
de leur gueule en permanence pour la vue
là dans l'escalator c'est une honte donc
c'est la télé réalité en plus on se fout
l'organisme entendez ou sentimentalement
je suis avec quelqu'un mais je dirais
quand même ce cadet mathieu s'il n'avait
pas le caractère que j'ai aujourd'hui je
me serais suicidé non vraiment et oui
oui vraiment oui vraiment genève ots
loin même coup du bien première entrevue
comme il nous montre oh non non non ils
nous ont d'ailleurs même ma mère qui m'a
vu à la télévision m'a pas reconnue
c'est bien que de raison maintenant j'ai
une mâchoire thomas qui honnêtement je
peux vous en citer cinq ans ils m'ont
appelé moi airtel de nombreux
agriculteurs pour me dire on ne peut pas
laisser salir les missions comme ça
l'émission nous a tellement apporté
aucun qui n'était pas convenu c'est une
chose mais dire que du coup comme elle
ne vous a pas convenu c'est une émission
immonde
je ne sais pas j'ai pas dit ça évite les
j'ai pas dit que c'était une mauvaise
émission j'ai dit que c'était je
critiquais la façon dont il faisait ce à
l'horizon et d'envié ils ont notre vie
entre les mains derniers mois vous sait
ce qu'on perd on va inverser et si nous
on va prendre les paysans les caméras
puis on va finir madame le marchand en
dehors des caméras pied on verra qui va
rire
dany boon se relâcha beaucoup car il est
un peu tôt qui s'avoue jamais vous en
avez après karine lemarchand enfin j'ai
cité elle parce que l'accord
présentatrice mais la production vous
trouvez vous trouvez que c'est trop
caricatural mais c'est le jeu aussi bien
s'énonce airs il alors dans votre jambe
n'était banni ce que je comprends pas
c'est que ces gens le critiquent je
pourrais longtemps des candidates zoo
une ici et quand dès la saison 7 nous
habiller la télévision vous avez regardé
de nancy premier non j'ai été
j'étais vraiment naïf et même cette
émission là ce soir de temps à l'école
attendez par contre on va revenir je
suis là ni toi je suis la convection
zaïdi on est un peu naïf
pourquoi je vais penser à l'amour est
dans le pré je vais vous expliquer je
vais jouer de l'accordéon partout des
filles j'en vois partout très bon t'es
s'intéresse au bac et sur la scène mais
ne s'intéresse pas à moi donc j'ai dit
je vais faire une émission et je vais
montrer comme je suis j'ai fait
confiance il y avait des émules et
comment des séquences que que j'ai
partagé avec eux et les salons pas
montré mais si j'ai d'une grosse
connerie abbas a pas l'opinon alors déjà
et vous j'ai eu peur d'être répondre à
isabelle qui énonce des contrevérités
terrible j'avais une émission j'ai
changé d'avis pourquoi parce qu'il ya
des gens comme dany qui ont critiqué
l'émission et qui ont été abandonnés par
la production la production à l'aise
dans les airs niveau de la production
ah ben j'imagine je téléphone un petit
coup de talent à karine et où carine
même appel c'est super que ça va c'est
génial
comment je veux dire pour moi j'ai rien
trop à dire ça m'a fait sortir
aujourd'hui je vais dans tous les
départements je connaissais pas mais bon
j'ai quand même eu des gens j'ai des
gentils c'est cyril j'ai des grandes
z'oreilles j'écoute bien je t'avais un
mec il me tirait d une disette des
conneries de moi un à deux mètres de moi
avec sa famille qui cinq minutes après
il dit en 2-1 est ce qu'on peut faire
une photo bon j'ai dit oui on peut faire
une photo je suis d'une photo même les
gens qui m'aiment pas je les aime quand
même mois aujourd'hui les gens
aujourd'hui ça leur prend tellement au
dessus le lot carrasso ou la fois que
vous êtes devenu excusez moi je la
tenais un personnage de télé et de télé
réalité vous avez profité mais le preuve
c'est que dans cette émission ils sont
obligés comme quoi qu'on en dise au
début c'était un peu authentique ça
l'est beaucoup moins
ils sont obligés de tout organiser parce
que les rencontres entre ceux qui se
rend compte qu'ils n'ont rien à dire
soit y avait comment ça va toi c'est
bien toi
par exemple comme thierry paris en tirer
toi tu adores négocier tu as bien venir
négocier avant d'acheter la même négocié
ton costume regarder parce que ça les
personnages caméra le premier prime de
la maison le mec indie battu fait comme
suit paul en jeu mais dans un
supermarché gens ferment la porte no
deal avait là la porte dans la caméra
trop cher pour ce que je peux y mettre
145 km h est séparable s'est par contre
moi je te perds on n'a pas volé les
messieurs joubert liquide
la coop non son boulot dit que nous ne
sommes tous allés et dans un intense et
montoir elle effraie le thierry
d'enfants voyage exceptionnel dont ils
ont besoin de caricature alors je suis
pas moi vous dites souvent que l'amour
est dans le pré
ça se moque des agriculteurs oui je sais
c'est votre aux bears à ce que ça se
moquer ce qu'on rit 2,2 g mois here le
casting et c soit légale soit une
caricature absolue lors du pardon mais
on est trop dans les détails mais ben
oui on a paniqué a gagné ce que vous
trouvez que il vous caricature bah oui
bien sûr il ya toujours le bon et le
méchant louis jumeaux moyennant mais
voilà il est à toi là il ya des cas
d'amérique alors justement guillaume
houde et qui était le premier candidat
gay en 2015 bien avant thomas de cette
année et il est parti très fâché avec la
production
voilà c'était un autre voilà non mais il
est passé il est parti très fâché
j'ai eu l'impression que j'ai
l'impression d'avoir été un phénomène de
foire car il n'arrêtait pas de dire que
j'en étais pas un mais forcément quand
on dit ça en permanence j'avais
l'impression vraiment qu'elle disait ça
volontairement pour le côté produits
voilà c'est ce qui s'est passé par la
suite voilà ça éclate et que son retour
- la production défendre le programme on
parle un peu de vraie vie ou une fois on
a des profils qui sont un édit et qui ne
sont pas aseptisé et vous parliez
d'années dont le dany c'est la manière
dont l'émission était fait
il ya un suivi psychologique et fait
qu'il ait pas la pression je suis à
cette voie là aussi ça a été comme lui
elle m'a dit qu'est ce que
alors j'ai dit qu'est-ce qu'il faut
poser vos questions elle m'a dit bah
vous me dites ce que vous avez envie je
suis d'un humour aux pêcheurs
agriculteurs
elle a noté ça termine et c'est là un
portefeuille à une gaine ces colonnes
tout et en plus de ça en parallèle il ya
la rédactrice en chef et la productrice
également donné depuis des années peu
importe quoi il a abattu mais n'est pas
le brame de seconde mine de rien
chérissez ans un programme qui nous fait
faire le tour de france mois chez moi
deux alors je vous le dis mais moi
j'avais j'aimais beaucoup les
agriculteurs depuis l'amour est dans le
pré
je suis voilà je suis en admiration
devant votre métier devant ce que vous
faites non le d'avancé ils n'ont plus
beaucoup plus notre sens et oui parce
que je connaissais pas bien et grâce à
l'amour est dans le pré maintenant
vraiment je vous le dise tous les
agriculteurs qui me regarde moi je suis
vraiment je me dis
j'aimerais être comme eux mais j'ai
l'impression vraiment que vous êtes
voilà je trouve que vous avez une
éthique de vie incroyable ça mais ce que
vous faites c'est un métier formidable
et vraiment je veux à d'autres essais
grâce à l'amour est dans le pré mais là
c'est grâce à l'amour est dans tes pas
aujourd'hui que je vous jure parfois je
me dis même j'ai envie de tout laisser
jean richard
j'aimerais être comme eux nommés frères
ils regardent passer huit jours chez moi
il fait marcher les cochons dont fait
une émission pour aller aux écuries et
les paysans et les chemises à carreaux
mais je pense non mais franchement c'est
une question et pour les agriculteurs
s'attendent à me la tendresse je vais
vous dire un truc moche main pour faire
de l'ordinateur mais je sais pas combien
j'en émission ne prend pas la tête moi
faut pouvoir était le regarder un peu
les ordinateurs tout ça parce que ça
tacle de ciboule ans après j'ai pas de
plateau à faire mais je me casse pas la
tête chez pas de deux sorties et ben je
me respecte mes vaches sont au cas moi
je me couche dans le champ le nez qui
vient du flair talent qui menait avec
ses mélodies va après ce qu'on peut
passer une semaine chez toi tu es louis
avec moi et trois chroniqueurs on y va
mais j'invite mai mais jamais ouais
j'adore cette émission people